ce que les animaux nous murmurent à
l'oreille parce qu'en fait ce ne sont
pas les hommes qui murmure à l'oreille
des animaux ce ne sont pas les femmes
d'ailleurs non plus ce sont les animaux
qui nous disent des choses
il suffit d'être attentif à la façon
dont ils nous parlent et à la façon dont
il se comporte
est ce que vous savez par exemple que
lorsqu une truie gratte le sol avant sa
mise bas c'est parce qu'elle cherche à
faire un nid pour son petit et que
d'ailleurs si elle va trouver ça peut
trouver des branchages ou des feuilles
elle va les mettre à l'intérieur pour
garnir sony est ce que vous avez
également que les femelles merle sont
attirés par les mâles en fonction de la
couleur de leur bec et qu'elles ont tout
à fait raison de le faire parce qu'en
fait chez le merle plus il a un bec d'un
bel orangé et meilleur sera son statut
immunitaire est d'ailleurs ce lien qui a
été trouvé entre l'attirance des
femelles pour la couleur du bec et le
statut immunitaire du mal a été trouvé
par l'équipe d' écologie comportementale
à l'université de bourgogne
juste à côté d'ici comment est ce que je
sais c'est différentes choses parce que
je suis et aux log est ce que quelqu'un
dans cette salle c'est ce qu'elle est au
logis de ce côté là de la file un petit
peu plus
vous n'êtes pas très nombreux ça me
rappelle mon conseiller pôle emploi
la première fois que j'allais le voir et
il m'a demandé quel était le titre du
dernier diplôme que j'avais obtenu
éthologie ce à quoi il m'a répondu d'une
façon très sûr de lui ah non ethnologie
ce à quoi je lui ai répondu que j'étais
vraiment désolée mais je n'avais pas
fait cinq années d'études pour me
tromper au final sur le nom de nos
diplômes alors il était assez gêné et il
m'a expliqué que oui mais bon il n'y
avait pas de case pour écologie dans son
logiciel
ce que je peux tout à fait comprendre
nous sommes 12 à sortir chaque année
d'éthologie appliquée je peux comprendre
que pôle emploi n'est pas créer deux
cases pour nous mais quand même ça m'a
toujours un petit peu embêté cette
histoire de cases de nous vouloir être
dans une case ou dans une autre et
d'ailleurs si on veut définir simplement
l'éthologie l'éthologie c'est l'étude
scientifique du comportement à nîmes
l'humain y compris et je ne devrais même
pas précisé humains y compris
l'humain est un animal biologiquement
comme les autres il n'ya pas avoir de
cases pour les humains d'un côté et une
case pour les animaux de l'autre en
l'occurrence les unions toujours
apprécié être dans une case distinctes
et on les voit notamment avec les
primatologues qui ont toujours voulu
définir le groupe qui les concerne donc
les primates la route sont des êtres
humains en contraire des autres animaux
ils ont par exemple dit au départ que
seuls les primates étaient capables de
se servir d'outils au jour aujourd'hui
on sait que de nombreux autres animaux
sont capables de se servir d'outils et
notamment des corbeilles des corneilles
pas d'appareil des corneilles qui sont
capables de prendre un bâton pour aller
chercher une friandise au fond d'une
bouteille les primatologues ont ensuite
dit que c'était peut-être la capacité de
faire de l'élevage qui définissait le
groupe des primates en l'occurrence on
sait aujourd'hui que les fourmis sont
capables d'élever les pucerons pour
l'heure miellat et qu'elles sont même
capables de laisser un tas de végétaux
volontairement en décomposition pour
ensuite ont récolté les champignons
qu'ils ont pris ont poussé certains
primatologue ont même dit que seuls les
primates étaient capables de ressentir
les émotions
pourtant aujourd'hui on sait qu'un grand
nombre de vertébrés sont capables de
ressentir des émotions simples comme la
joie la peur ou la tristesse et ça
concerne bien évidemment les chimpanzés
et les dauphins mais aussi les lézards
et les pigeons alors certes il ya tout
de même des différences indéniable entre
l'espèce humaine et les autres espèces
animales
par exemple seuls les êtres humains sont
capables de résoudre une équation à deux
inconnues et encore pas tous d'ailleurs
de même seuls des êtres humains sont
capables de ressentir des émotions très
complexes comme la nostalgie ou leur gré
et c'est vrai que c'est pas toujours
facile de savoir quelle est la de savoir
quels sont ces comportements au ses
caractéristiques qui sont propres êtres
humains et ceux qui sont partagées par
les autres animaux et je voudrais vous
l'illustré au travers de cette affiche
sa fiche qu'est ce qu'elle nous dit sur
cette vache elle nous dit que son rêve
pour la fête des mères voir grandir son
bébé mais cela n'arrivera pas essayons
d'analyser d'un point de vue écologique
cette affiche alors son rêve
est ce que les vaches rêve oui tout à
fait la plupart des mammifères partage
avec nous les mêmes phases de sommeil et
notamment la phase de sommeil paradoxal
et je suis sûr d'ailleurs que ceux
d'entre vous dans cette salle qui ont
des chats ou des chiens ont déjà vu
leurs animaux de compagnie en train
d'aboyer en train de feu les gens voient
qui acquiescent que nous dit d'autres
cette affiche que la vache souffre lors
de la séparation de son veau oui c'est
vrai surtout dans le cas d'une
séparation abrupte et précoce comme aux
premiers jours de vie comme c'est le cas
dans la plupart des élevages laitiers
la vache et le veau souffre pendant les
24 à 48 premières heures voire jusqu'à
une semaine
est ce que cette vache est capable alors
qu'elle est séparée de son veau de se
souvenir du moment où elle était avec
son veau de comparer ces deux situations
et de se dire qu'elle n'est pas bien
maintenant comme le sous-entend cette
affiche ça ce n'est pas possible ce
n'est pas possible parce que les vaches
n'ont pas cette conscience cette
capacité de pouvoir se projeter en tant
qu'individu dans un présent alternatif
ou dans un futur moi je peux me dire en
ce moment que je pourrais tu dehors et
que j'aurai froid mais que je suis au
chaud et que je suis bien et cette vache
n'est pas capable de faire
en fait ce que fait cette affiche c'est
de l'anthropomorphisme et
l'anthropomorphisme c'est une pratique
qui est très prisé par les antispécistes
alors anthropomorphisme d'abord un
premier mot nouveau peut-être qui est le
fait de d'attribuer une caractéristique
humaine un animal qui ne la détient pas
et donc comme je vous le disais cet
anthropomorphisme est souvent utilisée
par les antispécistes les antispécistes
sont des personnes qui estime qu'aucune
espèce n'est supérieure à une autre en
l'occurrence que les êtres humains ne
sont pas supérieurs aux autres espèces
animales et qu'il faut donc abolir toute
forme d'exploitation ni mal les outils
spéciaux
sont par définition contre toute forme
de domestication et sur ce point
notamment
personnellement je n'ai rejoint
absolument pas parce que je pense que la
domestication et l'une des plus bel
accomplissement de l'espèce humaine
en fait ceux qui utilisent
l'anthropomorphisme et ceux qui sont
antispécistes pose la question de savoir
si nous pouvons ou si nous devons tuer
des animaux pour nous nourrir
mais en l'occurrence quand on y
réfléchit un petit peu c'est une
question d'être humain sur nos droits
d'être humain donc c'est une question
avec nos yeux d'êtres humains mais
est-ce qu'on se pose la question de
savoir l'animal lui ne quoi est-ce qu'il
a besoin
ça ce sont les éthologues qui le font
les éthologues essaye de regarder avec
le regard de l'animal pour savoir quand
est ce qu'un animal et bien qu'est ce
qui fait qu'un animal se sent bien on
arrive ici à la notion de bien être
animal et cette notion elle a été
définie scientifiquement notamment par
des éthologues et on sait quoi ni mal et
bien globalement lorsqu'il est bien
nourri
lorsqu'il ne souffre pas de maladie ou
de blessures lorsqu'il peut exprimer des
comportements normaux et lorsqu'ils
ressentent des émotions positives
est ce bien être animal comme il est
défini avec les yeux des animaux
on peut tous l'appliquer au quotidien de
différentes façons et je voudrais voulu
illustrer avec deux exemples très
pratique
le premier concerne tous les animaux
domestiques et qui sont autour de nous
ce sont tous ces animaux grégaires donc
qui vivent en groupes qui ont besoin de
vivre en groupe à l'exception du chat le
chat est un félin et comme la plupart
des félins sont des animaux solitaires
le chat en fait supporter de vivre en
groupe mais n'a pas besoin de vie en
groupe mais mettons chaque côté pour
l'instant toutes les autres espèces de
meetic et domestiques et sont tous d
espèce grégaire vous voulez les poules
dans votre jardin
excellente idée mais prenez deux poules
pour qu'elle soit bien
vous voulez une chèvre naine pour
entretenir votre terrain c'est une très
bonne chose mais prenez deux chèvres
pour qu'elle se sente bien
vous avez l'intention d'acquérir un
cheval et de placer dans un pré encore
une fois c'est une très bonne idée mais
placez les dans une prairie où il sera
avec d'autres chevaux pour ne pas
souffrir d'isolement et pour ne pas
ressentir les nombreuses frustrations
comportementale qui sont liées à
l'isolément d'un animal grégaire pour le
deuxième exemple je voudrais vous parler
de la consommation et des produits de
consommation
j'espère j'imagine que si je vous
demande à tous
comment vous consommez comment vous
achetez vos yeux pour me répondait tout
ça délits sont en plein air et je vous
dirais vous avez tout à fait raison de
le faire parce que l'élevage de poules
en cage n'est absolument pas compatible
avec ces comportements d'ailleurs
personnellement je suis vraiment
persuadé que celui qui a inventé qui a
imaginé l'élevage de poules en batterie
n'avait jamais vu une foule de sa vie
c'est pas possible autrement mais
revenons à ces poules pour comprendre de
quoi elles ont besoin
il peut être intéressant de regarder
quelles sont leurs ancêtres sauvage il
se trouve que l'ancêtre sauvage qui est
commun à toutes les poules et toutes les
poulets que nous domestique on sait le
code banques y va c'est un joli petit
comme doré qui vit encore dans les
jungles d'asie et si je vous dis qui vit
dans les jungles c'est parce qu'en fait
c'est assez important
il vit en permanence dans un couvert
arboré pourquoi c'est important parce
que ce petit coq est très joli mais qui
n'est pas très agile et que du coup pour
pouvoir se protéger des prédateurs ils
se perche et c'est pour ça que par
exemple la nuit systématiquement il va
se chercher dans les arbres est
d'ailleurs plus se perchent haut et plus
sa place dans la hiérarchie est élevé si
on revient à notre poule pondeuse
aujourd'hui que nous élevons l'élever en
cage bon je pense que vous avez bien
compris ça c'est pas possible pour le
comportement naturel de l'animal
l'élever en plein air oui c'est mieux
les levés en plein air arborez comme
c'est le cas dans certains labels rouges
par exemple oui là c'est bien mieux
et là on a un système d'élevage qui
correspond au comportement naturel de
l'animal et qui va lui permettre de
pouvoir profiter au max
de l'espace qui lui donnait l'extérieur
parce qu'elle le cette poule ne va pas
craindre de sortir à l'extérieur pour
conclure j'espère vous avoir permis de
prendre un petit peu de recul par
rapport à cette notion de bien être
animal qui est assez présente en ce
moment dans les médias
j'espère vous avoir permis de prendre du
recul sur le piège de
l'anthropomorphisme parce que c'est un
piège dans lequel nous tombons
naturellement et c'est tout à fait
normal puisque nous sommes des êtres
humains nous avons toujours vu avec nos
êtres humains mais des scientifiques des
éthologues notamment regarde et son nom
la capacité de voir avec les yeux des
animaux donc
écoutons les éthologues quand ils nous
disent qu'une poule n'est pas fait pour
vivre en cage mais qu'elle doit vivre
dans un espace plein air et arboré de
préférence écoutons les éthologues quand
ils nous disent qu'un poulet ce n'est
pas fait pour vivre entassés dans un
bâtiment et qu'il est bien mieux dans un
espace plein air et arboré comme la
poule pondeuse écoutons encore les
éthologues quand ils nous disent que les
cochons ne sont pas faits pour vivre
enfermés dans des bâtiments et sur des
sols nus et qu'ils sont bien mieux
lorsqu'ils sont dans un élevage sur
paille par exemple pour pouvoir
retourner du substrat avec leur groupe
et en repensant à tous ces élevages qui
existent notamment les élevages en cage
les élevages en bâtiment je voudrais
vous citer une phrase de coluche qui me
semblent particulièrement pertinente
aujourd'hui et qui dit et dire qu'il
suffirait que les gens n'achètent plus
pour que ça ne se vendent pas